[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je pense que
les plus belles découvertes se font au
bout de la rue ce que j'aime c'est
découvrir notre beau pays avec des
personnes exceptionnelles et souvent
insolites
alors je vous emmène avec moi nous
sommes dans le département des yvelines
cette semaine un département très vert
puisque près de 30 % de sa surface est
recouverte de bois et de forêts vous
avez toujours rêvé de voir des
chevreuils des dindes et singulier en
liberté et ben moi aussi c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris rendez vous avec ambroise
aux portes de la forêt
nous sommes plus précisément à l'espace
rambouillet un parc animalier
gigantesque géré par l'office national
des forêts
[Musique]
à leur endroit où est-ce que tu va
m'emmener eh bien je vais te faire
découvrir aujourd'hui l'espace
rambouillet ouais et on va parcourir une
partie des 250 hectares du site et
notamment
je vais commencer par vous montrer les
grands cervidés qu'on a pris dans ce
parc à savoir cerfs et chevreuils
d'accord et alors sinon le parc joie qui
a différentes couleurs
cela correspond à différents espaces
j'imagine qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
l'espace rambouillet basiquement on peut
dire qu'il ya trois grandes activités
sur le site
tout d'abord un grand enclos de près de
200 hectares avec des grands animaux de
nos forêts à savoir cerf sanglier
chevreuil est aussi un petit peu de thym
on va commencer par la rédaction du
soleil
allez on y va
[Musique]
ambroise l'espace rambouillet il existe
depuis déjà une quarantaine d'années
c'était quoi le projet aux débats le
projet c'était de faire un parc
animalier au coeur de la forêt domaniale
de rambouillet qui ne ferait assez
emblématique et l'idée c'était de
pouvoir présenter des animaux de nos
forêts à un public de citadins c'était
déjà un petit peu visionnaire à l'époque
et cette vision initiale
eh ben elle a été conforté par les
tendances de la société
aujourd'hui c'est une idée qui a encore
plus de force qu'à l'époque de sa
création
donc le principe c'est que c'est des
animaux qui sont bas pas complètement
liberté mais quand même en liberté cesa
exactement en forme à dire semi-naturels
il ya quand même un enclos mais c'est un
énorme enclos à l'intérieur duquel les
animaux peuvent se déplacer relativement
librement et il concerne leur
comportement naturel et ça permet aux
gens de les voir sans barrières ce qui
procure aussi une émotion différente
et puis alors c'est pas instantanée non
plus ce à dire qu'il faut marcher un
petit peu observé et quand on rend
l'animal s'approcher un petit peu au
départ on a un petit peu anxieux
ça se mérite en fait ça se mérite on
peut le dire comme ça tout à fait on va
voir si on méritait si on met les années
où je crois qu'on est sur la bonne
direction
[Musique]
alors ça par exemple c'est des crottes
de quoi alors sont des crottes de serre
en fait le petit truc pour se fixer les
idées quand c'est de la taille d'une
olive comme ça c'est plutôt du cerf
biche et chevreuils qui aussi dans cette
partie du parc ça sera plus de la taille
d'un noyau d'olive et si on regarde
attentivement à côté on voit aussi
une empreinte oui les deux les deux
doigts en fait est là de cette taille là
c'est plutôt un cerf ou une niche
d'accord
si on regarde le boulot qui est juste
devant nous et on voit qu'il est un
petit peu
adimi abîmé et ben en fait ça c'est le
résultat en fait d'une action dessert
tous les ans ils perdent ils refont leur
bois leurs coiffes et au début de la
formation de la peau encore sur les sur
les bois il ya un moment donné ça va
craquer et ils ont besoin de se se
frotter les bois sur des arbres d'accord
ici ça fait que c'est qu'ils
affectionnent particulièrement les
boulots mais les y frotte pas qu'un peu
la visite
ah oui et non et bien c'est bien récurer
exactement ou alors ça veut dire aussi
qu'on est sur le bon chemin
exactement ils ont déjà repéré alors ils
repèrent plus à loder et au bruit très
bonne vue il va pas les couleurs il voit
surtout les mouvements
[Musique]
on les voit courir alors est-ce que ce
qui est de la compétition s qui en a un
qui court plus vite que l'autre entre
les serres et les chevreuils
alors il n'y a pas forcément de
compétition entre mais c'est clair que
le chevreuil cours plaisir ça doit
passer juste à gauche là et en fait on
voit ces bondissant c'est pas la même
taille ses 35 kg le crc plutôt 150 kg et
c'est une allure qui se rapproche plus
du lapin haut du lièvre
ok mon 10 ans a fait des zigzags alors
que le cerf avec ses 150 kg et bien il
est beaucoup plus massif et il pourra -
faire des virages
moi j'entends souvent parler du brame du
cerf ci qu'est ce que c'est
le brame du cerf c'est quelque chose de
très particulier qu'on peut comparer un
peu on rejoue enregistrement du lion
dans la savane
c'est la période de reproduction
c'est une période où en fait le
le servent à bram et donc ces fameux cri
rauque pour défier les autres mâles et
pour aussi séduire les femelles et la
particularité c'est qu'en fait tu auras
de l'intimidation et parfois jusqu'à du
combat entre les différents mal pour
avoir un seul élu qui va pouvoir aller
dans l'aar de biche et s'accoupler mais
sachant qu'après pour une morale
complète c'est la biche qui décide ou
pas de l'accouplement d'accord à la
casse un peu le mythe élimination de
voilà c'est pas le harem soumis
alors ici mènent les petits peuvent se
balader dans les arbres c'est ça peuvent
se balader ils peuvent grimper dans les
arbres en toute sécurité
on est devant une passerelle suspendue
dans les arbres est ce qu'on appelle
l'odyssée verte c'est brevetée par
l'office national des forêts et ça
permet aux plus petits aussi aux plus
grands en fait d'accéder progressivement
dans sa monte dans les grandes branches
ce qu'on appelle les houppiers des
arbres les enfants vont d'abord sentir
un petit peu ce que ça fait d'être en
hauteur dans les arbres
et puis après au niveau de chaque
plateforme qui entoure les gros chêne il
ya
des panneaux pédagogiques qui explique
comment fonctionne une forêt et est ce
que la forêt progresse en france ou pas
des choses comme ça donc c'est une
manière de d'apprendre tout en étant
sur l'activité un peu ludique un peu
rigolote ouais bah oui c'est moi aussi
j'ai envie de monter en moi dans une
autre partie du parc se trouve les
rapaces que l'on peut admirer en vol
lors de démonstrations j'y retrouve
justin elle est passionnée par ces
animaux impressionnants et ses petits
chouchous ce sont les chouettes et les
hiboux
comment s'appelle le c'est un garçon on
suppose que c'est une femelle parce
qu'elle a un peu plus lourde en fait
faut s'arracher les rapaces la femme
elle est toujours plus l'autre que les
mâles donc on pense que c'est une
femelle qui s'appelle willow bonjour
vélo tu es fou connurent non ça se dit
pas ça c'est mon papa féminiser le terme
ça va être chaud cogner pourquoi parce
que la fauconnière en fait c'est le sac
au mélange
oui d'accord pour nous assal intéressant
willow et je me demandais comment tu
arrives à communiquer justement avec les
oiseaux enfin avec les rapaces alors ça
ça force d'observation il n'y a pas
vraiment de communication verbale et
forcément même si on se met à siffler
avec eux c'est très subjectif en fait
donc c'est vraiment de l'observation de
l'animal voir comment il réagit à
certaines situations et quillan on
s'adapte en fonction d'accords
parmi toutes les espèces parce qu'il ya
plein de il ya plein d'animaux
différents ici et plein de rapaces
différents est-ce qu'il y en a un plus
particulièrement qui t'impressionne plus
ou qui est on c'est vrai qu'à force de
travailler avec eux il n'y a pas de
préférence c'est tout le temps que les
aime tous pareils cette hausse de
l'émerveillement et c'est
c'est incroyable quoi pouvoir bosser
avec ce genre de d'oiseaux c'est fou
après c'est vrai que les nocturnes voilà
ils sont trés c'est des petites boules
wibp envie de rester avec eux et puis
surtout il au bas du coup c'est moi qui
m'en suis occupé donc je dirais ce
peut-être ma chouchou mais mais sinon
dans tous les soirs pendant tous les
oiseaux c'est un rapport différent à
chaque fois et c'est vraiment top guido
est bien une particularité un peu comme
ses amis c'est qu'elle tourne sa tête
vraiment dans tous les sens 270°
pourquoi en fait il arrive à faire ça
alors c'est un zombie d'un particulier
en fait les nocturnes donc les ebooks
peuvent pas bouger leurs yeux dans les
orbites donc ce qu'ils ont appris à
compenser en fait
et pour ce faire ils peuvent tourner la
tête à 270 degrés après cette petite
entrée en matière justine et son
collègue jean baptiste me réservent une
surprise
une démonstration de vol rien pour nous
où je me retrouve au centre de l'arène
face à un très gros pygargue à tête
blanche
quand tu veux jean baptiste voilà là tu
peux tourner su faire encore
punaise ça va vite ouais ça va être vite
nickel
alors lui comment il s'appelle lucem
marley et c'est quoi comme race plus
spécifique nous c'est un pygargue à tête
blanche c'est l'emblème des états unis
d'amérique
il est impressionnant je dois dire une
émotion forte
et puis et puis c'est très grand en fait
je me rendais pas compte mais quand il
est arrivé sur moi je me suis dit waouh
ouais on aux alentours de 2 mètres 50
d'envergure quelque chose comme ça donc
ça commence à faire affaire grand
contient un oiseau qui arrivent dans
notre main comme ça je trouve qu'on a
l'impression d'être une personne
privilégier non c'est sûr tous les jours
c'est ce qu'on se répète d'ailleurs ça
nous sommes nos instants pendant le
spectacle
c'est cet instant privilégié c'est sûr
c'était émouvant de recevoir un aigle
sur son bras je me dis c'est des métiers
quand même une part le tiens celui de
justine où on est proche
enfin proche de la passion et qu'est ce
que tu aimes toi dans ton travail ici
alors ce que j'apprécie particulièrement
en fait c'est le lien avec la terre
en fait c'est quelque chose qui m'a
guidé depuis que j'étais tout petit
c'est tout simplement lié à une histoire
familiale
mon grand père est agriculteur et donc
j'ai des bons souvenirs dans les champs
avec des bottes de foin de choses comme
ça et je sais qu'ici il ya un aspect
plaisir dans ce qu'on peut vivre ou
montrer plaisir personnel et ça nourrit
aussi la réflexion professionnelle
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on a
évidemment aussi nos soucis dans ces
métiers là il ya de la gestion
financière humaine où des tensions et
c'est donc ça il faut pas avoir une
vision trop
idéalisée de ce métier se reconnecter
n'est pas fiable
[Rires]
mais oui c'est ça aussi la nature là on
peut pas rien et voilà tout tout n'est
pas carré est prévu à l'avancé
il ya une forme d'humilité à garder et
derrière tout n'est pas prévisible
on doit s'adapter aux temps de la nature
bah merci beaucoup hongroise et puis si
vous voulez revoir cette rencontre la
forêt de rambouillet rendez vous sur
terre de france pointent tv et nous on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
rencontres
[Musique]